l'Apple watch série 8 est arrivé alors
elle est arrivée elle est pas dans la
boîte elle est à mon poignée je me
balade avec je m'amuse aussi et ça ça
c'est bien l'appel on va chez réduite ça
c'est l'Apple watch Série 7 je voudrais
déjà qu'on commence par regarder un
petit peu les différents design voir si
c'est des démons qui sont vraiment
similaires ou alors s'il y a vraiment
des grosses différences par rapport à
ces deux produits spoiler LRT elle se
ressemble énormément c'est quasiment la
même chose je dis bien quasiment pas
tout à fait il y a des différences
forcément Apple s'ils sont une nouvelle
montre on s'attendra ce qui nous met des
différences on va donc regarder
aujourd'hui quels sont les nouveautés
apportées par cet Apple watch série 8
voir un petit peu où elle en est par
rapport à ce qu'on peut faire à ce qu'on
attend d'une montre connectée que ce
soit en terme de lifestyle que ce soit
en termes de santé que ce soit en termes
d'exercice bref on va faire un tour
complet cet Apple watch série 8 pour
savoir au bout du bout au bout du bout
du bout du bout du bout si elle est
faite pour vous alors pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec rhinoshield
alors exceptionnellement pour la sortie
de l'iPhone 14 vous avez moins 15% sur
tout le site de rhinoshield avec le code
gros 22
grrr22 - 15% faut y aller je vous mets
le lien en bas dans la description alors
vous connaissez probablement rhinoshield
je vous en ai énormément parlé ils font
des coques pour smartphone ils font des
coques de protection également pour vos
airpods et airpods Pro 2 notamment mais
également pour les Apple watch si vous
voulez donc venir protéger si votre
APPLE watch vous avez de quoi faire
contre les chocs design personnalisable
100% sans BPA nift à lattes pouvez venir
la personnaliser avec plus d'une dizaine
de couleurs que ce soit la Bordure
Extérieure par exemple en bleu avec un
petit contour intérieur rouge parce que
vous voulez vous pouvez même mettre un
petit peu d'orange à vous de voir ici
complètement vous protéger contre les
chocs mais il existe également un écran
de protection antichoc 3D pour votre
Apple watch Apple watch series vite
Série 7 45 mm par exemple ici vous venez
la mettre directement ici sur votre
APPLE Watch et ça viendra la protéger
contre les chocs et les rayures à noter
que vous avez toujours les références au
catalogue pour l'Apple watch je vous
l'ai dit serrer cette série 8 mais
également la 4 5 6 se et S2 si vous
souhaitez donc je vous invite à venir
jeter un coup d'oeil aussi de
rhinoshield je vous mets le lien une
fois de plus dans la description et
n'oubliez pas les -15% grâce à la sortie
de l'iPhone 14 et le code Greux 22 et ça
c'est vachement bien et merci à rinoshi
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
l'Apple watch série 8 est très
clairement une évolution de l'Apple
watch Série 7 elle se ressemble
énormément on va avoir le même type de
boîtier on va avoir du 41 ou du 45 mm
les tailles ne changent pas on va avoir
un écran incurvé on va avoir du always
on display on va voir la même chose
qu'on avait sur l'Apple watch Série 7
avec quelques petits détails en plus
notamment un capteur que vous allez
avoir au dos c'est un capteur de
température alors attention le capteur
température s'adresse aux femmes et pas
aux hommes c'est pas une prise de
température à un instant T par exemple
si vous faites du sport vous allez pas
savoir à combien vous allez monte en
température c'est une prise de
température qui se fera la nuit ça veut
donc dire déjà qu'il faut prendre votre
montre il faut la mettre à votre poignée
qu'il faut dormir avec ça c'est déjà le
premier élément et surtout une prise de
température qui servira et Apple nous le
dit très clairement ici ça permet de
comprendre le cycle menstruel forcément
ici on s'adresse aux femmes et pas aux
hommes on l'aura compris moyen en fait
il vous le disent c'est un moyen simple
d'estimer votre date d'ovulation au
moment de l'ovulation il va y avoir une
augmentation de la température alors
attention c'est de l'ordre de 0,5 degrés
c'est globalement pas grand chose mais
la montre elle va le détecter lorsque
vous dormez lors des phases de sommeil
parce que la journée lorsque vous bougez
si ça la montre elle va avoir un peu
plus de mal parce que une fluctuation en
fonction de l'activité qu'on va faire
tous les jours tandis que la nuit on est
au repos la température normalement ne
bouge pas or pathologie ça serait quand
même relativement ballot donc elle va
pouvoir dire ok on connaît le début de
votre cycle au moment où arriver vos
règles c'est tout est bien rentré dans
votre application et au moment où vous
allez ovuler c'est à dire entre 12 et 14
jours après il va y avoir une
augmentation légère la température
pendant 10 à 12 jours et à ce moment-là
la honte vous dira tiens vous avez
ovuler à telle date elle va pas vous
dire vous allez au vu d'entendre le jour
et vous dit vous avez ovuler par exemple
il y a un jour de jour 3 jours donc ça
permettra effectivement d'avoir un suivi
du site qui est beaucoup plus précis
alors il y a un truc et rassurant ici au
niveau des données de santé il Apple
nous dit une fois de plus les données
sont stockées uniquement dans vos
appareils à son chiffrer et bien
évidemment protégé grâce à face id ou
grâce à votre code l'Apple watch on voit
il devient de plus en plus un acteur de
santé regardez vous le voyez ici lorsque
vous allez dans votre pointage que vous
allez vérifier vous voyez quasiment tout
vous voyez votre fiche médicale si par
exemple vous avez un accident et bien on
peut rapidement avoir des informations
sur votre groupe sanguin et si et ça
donc ça c'est cool les appels d'urgence
si vous avez un problème un accident la
détection des accidents qui se fait
grâce à un gyroscope qui est amélioré à
3 axes et grâce à un nouvel
accéléréomètre de force G élevé
l'algorithme va utiliser également votre
micro va utiliser le baromètre va
utiliser le GPS pour détecter un
accident et pouvoir appeler les secours
donc ça je trouve ça cool ça ça marche
aussi bien au niveau de votre iPhone que
votre APPLE watch donc dans les deux cas
c'est rassurant on a également la
détection des chutes vous pouvez choisir
de mettre pendant le sport ou alors tout
le temps la notification de faible
fréquence cardiaque c'est-à-dire vous
battez à 40 battements par minute
pendant 10 minutes à contrario la
notification élevée 120 BPN pendant 10
minutes la notification d'arythmie vous
avez votre application ECG pour faire un
électrocardiogramme attention il fallait
pas sur un produit médical c'est
vraiment pour avoir un estimatif la
notification de santé cardiovasculaire
la mesure de votre oxygène sanguin la
notification de stabilité de la marche
pour voir si vous avez un risque de
chute ou pas la notification d'écouteurs
si vous écoutez dans vos écouteurs
volume trop élevé il va vous le dire
pour dire protéger vos oreilles la
notification du bruit ambiance et par
exemple vous avez du bruit à plus de 80
décibels il va vous le dire pour venir
vous protéger ah ça vient s'ajouter le
suivi du sommeil alors il faut dormir
avec votre APPLE watch c'est pas trop
mon truc mais bon j'ai déjà fait pour
essayer donc vous venez dormir avec elle
vous dira quels sont vos périodes de
sommeil paradoxal de sommeil land de
sommeil profond vous verrez également
les phases d'éveil donc si vous voulez
vraiment savoir ce qui se passe au
niveau de votre sommeil vous pouvez le
faire et de toute façon si vous voulez
mesurer votre température corporelle il
faut dormir avec votre monde bon voilà
si vous la remets pas avec votre monde
vous ne profiterez pas de ces éléments
là et vous avez également une
application pour le traitement médicaux
qui vous dira tiens vous avez un
traitement à prendre à telle heure
prenez le tout de suite alors
normalement on le sait mais des fois
c'est un peu relou on peut ne pas être
tout le temps le nez sur son horloge en
disant tiens il faut que je prenne mon
médicament à ce moment-là et bien votre
monde va faire pour vous le rappeler
donc ça aussi c'est plutôt rassurant
donc on voit en fait que cet Apple watch
c'est un dispositif de santé et ça c'est
un élément fort donc l'Apple watch elle
sert pour la santé alors on se dirait ok
avec l'Apple watch série 8 on avance un
peu dans la santé mais on n'a pas de
grosse révolution on n'a pas le truc de
fou il est sûr de toute façon que cet
Apple watch avait déjà très avancé très
par rapport à ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du marché il
y a des rumeurs qui courent depuis je
crois un an un an et demi qui disent
qu'on attend un capteur de mesure
d'alcool dans le sang a priori l'Apple
watch pourrait le faire plus tard et
voyez en fait on voit que capteur après
capteur évolution après évolution on
arrive à des montres où tout doucement
on voit une évolution au niveau de la
Paloise mais on peut pas avoir une
évolution aussi flagrante qu'on a eu sur
certaines générations puisque c'est une
montre qui est déjà extrêmement bien
abouti à moins d'arriver sur une montre
qui est quand même relativement
différente et qui se destine à un autre
public et là je vous parle de l'Apple
watch ultra mais ça on en parlera une
prochaine fois donc je vous invite à
venir vous abonner et actionner la
cloche pour tout savoir quand on parlera
de l'Apple watch ultra notamment pas le
droit aussi d'autres choses ça c'est
bien donc on parle de santé mais on
parle également d'exercices de sport
parce que l'Apple Watch est également
une montre qui est là pour le sport ça
c'est pas tout nouveau sauf que là ce
qui a été modifié bien c'est d'un point
de vue logiciel une expérience qui va
être améliorée avec de nouvelles vues
lors de vos exercices et puis une
nouvelle fonction qui va bientôt arriver
qui n'est pas encore arrivé qui vous
permettra lorsque vous faites du sport
par exemple vous partez ici vous faites
le tour de quartier où j'en sais rien et
bien de vous donner toujours la position
vous permet de vous battre un peu contre
vous-même pour savoir si vous améliorez
votre score bon c'est un petit détail
mais ça peut être marrant c'est
également un outil de divertissement
enfin c'est pas tout nouveau non plus
c'est à dire que vous avez qu'à mettre
hop là j'écris de mieux en mieux vous
avez qu'à mettre vos airpods et vous
allez pouvoir écouter de la musique
lorsque vous courrez écouter un film
très facilement regardez par exemple un
film sur votre tablette sur votre iPad
piloter directement tout avec votre
APPLE watch écoute avec vos airpods ça
c'est la télé de l'écosystème et c'est
la force de l'écosystème c'est-à-dire
que cette Apple watch elle sert aux
divertissement mais pas que parce que
c'est une télécommande en quelque sorte
de vos appareils connectés Apple et puis
on servira également ici pour lifestyle
parce que on a une montre qui est belle
avec différentes finitions différents
bracelets il va y avoir énormément de
choix ici de disponibles parce que apple
l'a bien compris on parle ici à des
personnes qui aiment la mode qui aiment
l'élégance et qui veulent faire
attention qu'ils veulent choisir des
produits qui leur correspondent vous
avez différentes finitions l'aluminium
en titane le prix va forcément moduler
dans sachant que cette montre elle est
disponible à partir de 499 euros on se
parle donc d'un objet cher un objet très
cher mais qui sait faire tellement de
choses elle peut même venir vous sauver
la vie alors il votre nouveauté qui est
arrivé cette année c'est un mode spécial
que vous allez retrouver également si
vous avez une Apple watch à partir de
l'Apple watch série 4 c'est le mode
faible consommation d'énergie vous allez
pouvoir monter jusqu'à 36 heures
d'autonomie alors les Apple watch de
toute façon depuis le début du début du
début vous avez une journée d'autonomie
vous venez la rechargeur il y a un truc
qui a été amélioré et qui est
intéressant c'est la charge parce qu'ici
vous avez un bloc de charge qui a plus
vite alors il faut venir l'acheter en
plus ce que vous avez vous et bien
effectivement c'est votre cap de charge
mais le bloc il faut venir l'acheter en
plus vous la recharger rapidement donc
ça c'est quand même bien il y a un
bénéfice par rapport à ce qu'on avait
avant mais l'inconvénient de cette Apple
watch c'est que vous la garder une
journée et seulement une journée donc si
vous partiez j'en sais rien vous dire un
grand voyage dans un avion vous avez pas
la possibilité de venir vous recharger
si vous partiez plusieurs jours sans
avoir la possibilité de vous recharger
et bien vous étiez quand même un petit
peu bloqué donc là vous activez ce mode
et vous montez jusqu'à 36 heures
d'autonomie ça va venir supprimer
quelques éléments ça venir supprimer des
capteurs ça va venir supprimer la loi
zone display ça va venir minimiser un
peu l'expérience mais pour autant vous
allez l'emmener beaucoup plus loin avec
les fonctions essentielles donc en fait
cette Apple watts elle est bien plus
qu'une montre connectée elle ouvre un
peu plus la porte de la santé pré parce
que c'est une petite parenthèse que je
vous fais là mais on voit que dans le
monde de la santé on est aujourd'hui sur
ce qu'on appelle de la santé curative
c'est-à-dire que on voit qu'on a un
problème on va se faire soigner à
l'hôpital mais l'idée de tous ces objets
connectés et de l'Apple watch ici un peu
au centre de l'écosystème Apple c'est de
se dire et bien on a tellement de
capteurs qu'on va pouvoir capter des
choses avant même l'apparition des
symptômes d'une maladie aujourd'hui on
n'est pas capable de détecter des
cellules cancéreuses qui vont se balader
dans votre corps c'est pas le but mais
on en est vraiment pas là mais ça peut
être un peu le but ultime c'est à dire
qu'avec une montre au poignet et puis
différents capteurs qu'on pourrait
imaginer après avec des miroirs
connectés des choses comme ça et bien on
arriverait avec l'ensemble de ces
capteurs à pouvoir justement capter des
problèmes des pathologies des maladies
avant même leur apparition avant les
symptômes c'est à dire soigner les gens
avant l'apparition des symptômes et
avant l'apparition de la maladie c'est
tout l'enjeu de cette santé prédictive
qui d'une coûtera moins cher parce qu'on
passera moins de temps ici à venir ce
soigner sur un lit d'hôpital et surtout
on arrêtera les pathologies bien plus
tôt donc on voit que les Apple watch
année après année après année avec de
plus en plus de capteurs elle permet de
sensibiliser les gens avoir une
meilleure santé faire l'exercice on a
des capteurs on sait où on en est si et
ça et elle permettra au bout du bout
infinie à terme d'éviter l'apparition
des maladies et avoir une population en
meilleure santé alors on en est certes
pas encore là mais vous voyez avec tous
les capteurs avec tout ce qu'elle est
capable de faire par rapport à la
première génération c'est vraiment
vraiment évolué donc est-ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui venir acheter l'Apple
walkery 8 alors si vous avez une Apple
watch Série 7 je vois très clairement
pas du tout l'intérêt aujourd'hui ici
moi vous voulez avoir une mesure très
fine du moment où vous allez venir au
vueler alors on peut le faire également
avec un thermomètre une prise de
température c'est des choses qui
existent on peut venir le faire comme ça
donc si vous avez une Apple watch Série
7 gardez-la si vous avez une Apple watch
Série 6 et gardez-la si vous n'avez pas
d'Apple Watch et que vous voulez une
Apple watch autant aller sur l'Apple
watch série zut c'est quand même
vachement bien et très complète mais si
vous trouvez une Apple watch Série 7
moins cher en reconditionné d'occasion
vous pouvez y aller aussi les yeux
fermés parce qu'elle reste extrêmement
actuelle et puis il y en a une qui est
super canon et intéressante c'est
l'Apple watch se deuxième génération on
en parle très bientôt parce que c'est
peut-être l'Apple watch qu'il vous
faudra elle fera moins de choses elle
aura moins de capteurs mais elle aura
les fonctions essentielles qu'on attend
d'une Apple watch voilà ce que j'avais à
vous dire aujourd'hui sur cet Apple
watch série 8 moi je trouve super bien
super canon je la trouve beaucoup trop
cher 499 euros waouh est-ce que 500
balles la montre mais pour autant ce
qu'elle fait elle le fait drôlement bien
c'est vraiment une très jolie montre en
très belle déconnecté dans la mesure où
vous pouvez vous l'acheter alors on
parlera de l'Apple Watch et ce bientôt
qui je vous le dis une fois de plus elle
a un tarif qui est beaucoup plus
maîtrisé et qui est peut-être en fait
l'Apple Watch a acheté cette année en
2022 en attendant dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commentaire
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de toutes ces
fonctionnalités notamment au niveau de
la santé on voit que la partie exorciste
fitness sport et la partie santé
connectée sont intimement liés ici
est-ce que vous les utilisez oui non
est-ce que le suivi du sommeil c'est un
truc qui vous intéresse mesdames est-ce
que toute la partie suivie de
température pour votre ovulation c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse marquez
moi ça en bas dans les commentaires et
puis on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler d'Apple et encore
plein de produits à venir voir le test
définitif de l'iPhone 14 pro Max qui est
là si vous donnez mon retour très
bientôt on se parlera également de
l'Apple Watchers par également de
l'Apple watch ultra plein de choses à
raconter et ça c'est très cool je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]